AGAINST IT.
MIKE?
>> KEVIN CORKE LEADING US
OFF ON THE NORTH LAWN.
KEVIN, THANKS.
U.S. TEAM IS ON THE GROUND
TONIGHT ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA FURTHER EVIDENCE
THAT THE SUMMIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG
UN MAY IN FACT HAPPEN.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT GREG PALKOT IS
IN SEOUL TONIGHT.
>> A WHIRLWIND OF ACTIVITY
AHEAD OF THE PLANNED SUMMIT
INVOLVING PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM
JONG UN.
AT THE SCENE OF SATURDAY'S
SURPRISE SUMMIT WITH KIM AND
SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT MOON
JAE-IN ON THE NORTH KOREAN
SIDE OF THE DMZ U.S. AND
NORTH KOREAN TEAMS ARE
WORKING OUT THE DETAILS OF
THE POSSIBLE MEETING.
>> I THINK THE U.S. IS
TRYING TO ENGAGE NORTH
KOREA'S INTEREST IN
DENUCLEARIZATION AND WHAT
THAT MIGHT MEAN.
HOWEVER THEY ARE WILLING TO
GO.
>> HEADING UP THE HIGH
POWERED AMERICAN SIDE
AMBASSADOR TO THE
PHILIPPINES, FORMER
AMBASSADOR TO SOUTH KOREA
AND UNION NEGOTIATOR PSALM
KIM.
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL AFFAIRS
AL SOON HOOKER WHO
ACCOMPANIED IVANKA TRUMP AND
RANDAL SHRIVER WHO IS WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO LAST TRIP TO
PYONGYANG.
THEY ARE FACING OFF AGAINST
POWERFUL NORTH KOREAN VICE
FOREIGN MINISTER WII WHOSE
EXPLOSIVE REMARKS LAST WEEK
THREATENING THAT NUCLEAR TO
NUCLEAR SHOW DOWN AND
CALLING VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
A POLITICAL DUMMY ALMOST
BLEW THE SUMMIT OUT OF
WATER.
DEPUTY WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF JOE HAGIN AND OTHERS
WHO WITH THEIR NORTH KOREAN
COUNTERPARTS WILL PLAN
LOGISTICS TORE THE MEETING
WITH MORE NORTH SOUTH TALKS
PLANNED PRESIDENT MOON
CALLED FOR MORE DIALOGUE
POSSIBLY A THREE WAY SUMMIT
WITH THE NORTH AFTER
SINGAPORE.
>> I THINK WHAT PRESIDENT
MOON WAS TRYING TO DO WAS
RESTORE THE CHANNELS.
>> SET TO AGAIN HERE
TUESDAY.
THERE IS TALK OF ONE LAST
MEETING BETWEEN SECRETARY OF
STATE POMPEO AND NORTH
KOREAN OFFICIAL TO GET THE
FINAL GO AHEAD TO THE SUMMIT
IF ALL GOES WELL.